[Music]
all right so the year
is 2021. uh can we call it 20 20.5
20 20 points just do that for now why
you don't think it's 2021
i mean did you see what's happening well
it's 20.5 hey this is the year of mad
max
did you know what does that mean 2021
the movie
yeah yeah they thought that this would
be the yeah they're not right
it's not that far off no it's like way
far off oh it's true
fine but still and we're in a pretty
crazy place in uh in this
day and time but we're gonna be stuck in
2020 like for a long time
22 point five i mean we're gonna be
stuck in 22.5 okay but like it's gonna
be 20 22 it's like 20 20.3
yeah the 2020s is gonna be a long decade
i think
so uh in this day and age uh online
dating
has taken on a new right
meaning during the pandemic and lockdown
a lot of people
who are single out there have no options
other than to
date through uh hookup
apps and stuff like that and if you
remember
in the beginning of these hookup apps a
lot of people were very dismissive
towards
the idea that these would actually work
a lot of people thought they were just
you know
short-term relationship little slender
like tinder yeah
things like that and there was no real
hope for people finding genuine love
you know and this is like maybe probably
going back like almost 15 20 years ago
now i feel like with the
first thing back in the day yeah it was
like if you're if you're on a social
e-harmony come on yes e-harmony exactly
so if you're on one of these sites it's
kind of like oh you
you won't be able to find love you can't
find it in real life you're not going to
find it online and if you do find
anything online creatures
it's not going to last say that about
friendships too
really oh friends that you have online
are not your real friends
true i mean i do who makes up these
rules
it's so stupid i think it's the
unknowing it's the fear of something new
i would like to tell you that i was
really close to my video game and we
were like
[ __ ] homies you know what i mean like
on gta i had an
awesome first enter your video game no
i'm like the
video game friend oh like an ai you just
proved the point because you guys aren't
friends anymore
that's because i don't sign on
you ghosted them you did
all right so according to surveys uh and
this is
in the swiss this is in geneva they got
good cheese there dude
you got cheese or tea isn't it cheese
swiss cheese
he walked out of a restaurant chocolate
why why'd you watch watching
so you know like everywhere i go i want
to eat what like they're known for yeah
so when we were in switzerland they're
like they're known for their
cheese fondue so i'm like i have to get
cheese fondue
found the place i opened the door and i
almost
threw up immediately yeah why
so it just like you know like when it's
a really cold place
everyone always counters it with like
the most extreme amount of like heaters
so you could take off like your three
coats or whatever right that's true why
do they do that
i don't know so it's like super [ __ ]
hot and then the cheese
just smelled like extra punches extra
cheese like
athlete's foot so when i opened the door
just i don't even know it just smelled
so crazy i'm like oh [ __ ] i don't think
i could eat here
damn you can't you know like cheese
though they have a special scent like
it's different
yeah sticky tofu i wasn't saying you
walked out of there and you're like give
me some stinky tofu instead
yes but i i could you react to that i
was i
the fact that he wanted to walk out
first i was okay with it but he wanted
to walk out first and i'm like oh [ __ ] i
guess maybe it hasn't hit me yet i'm
like let's go
because he usually can smell worse
things than anybody here
remember yeah yeah so i was like [ __ ] i
why am i gonna gamble here like i'm
gonna leave before it hits me
oh sure that's damn damn you almost
threw up from a restaurant
from walking in you didn't even eat
anything yet i didn't even get to the
main restaurant you know places with
like bad weather they have like
the front door and another door you're
in like the hallway yeah in the hallway
i walked in and i'm like oh
[ __ ] yeah i'm not bad should i open the
second door just to see what happened i
couldn't
he would be i wasn't brave enough that
day
all right so back to the study um it is
being found that there are no
differences between couples who initiate
through dating apps
and those initiated elsewhere regarding
relationship and life satisfaction
oh cool yeah which is very to surprise
of a lot of uh
um i could call it psychologists and and
uh why would it be so surprising
i don't know i feel like there's a
stigma because the previous thought was
online isn't real so you're not
talking to a real person like energies
in front of you
but even if you met someone online and
you started dating in person there's
still a stigma behind
like where you met that's all you know
online now it's different right
but i always saw it as like if you can
okay like before dating online like
where did we go
as teens like we went to the mall or
like it was
a friend of a friend or like and then
you had to like kind of
present yourself and then go out right
so
your chances and how much time you have
is so low so like if you wanted to date
maybe outside of your race or try
something different outside of your
community
you couldn't do it because having access
to
maybe um i don't know like you're from
the valley and you want to surf a girl
or whatever right like it's so
limited but now you can just be in your
boxers
and just [ __ ] hit them up and then
you have like
hella choices and then because of that
you can find someone
who might fit you way better than the
limited choices that you have
in front of you that's true yeah so the
idea is that
uh having online dating apps has
gamified the the romance the romancing
through through these platforms
so that you have you're able to
basically put all your stats out you
know your likes your dislikes all that
all this stuff whereas in real life
you're kind of
just well we're going to wing it you
know we're going to go on this date and
we're going to see what this guy is like
or we'll see
what this girl is like and you know and
if we'll have to decide whether we like
it or not you know what i think it is
it's kind of like um
so compatibility versus chemistry
so i think like in person you get to
pick up on chemistry
initially and then figure out the
compatibility but then with online is
like
first figuring out compatibility and
then when you meet in person see if you
have that chemistry
oh that's a really good way to break it
down that's actually better
yeah yeah i like the way you just broke
down you just waste that which wastes so
much time
i think the the stigma comes from before
like if you were to do
online dating before like e-harmony or
whatever back then it would be like
people who are desperate this is their
last defense
right but now it's like on apps
everybody's doing it whether or not like
they're desperate it's just modern world
just like yeah every single person is on
the app if you're single
yeah before it was like when there was a
stigma like oh you met them on eharmony
so where do you make chicks at the bar
i'm like what isn't
the bar worse because it's like you're
putting your best then you can put up
the front of like oh i'm at the bar to
hang out my friends
if you're on eharmony it was like you're
on eharmony to find somebody yeah yeah
but then at least like all your stats
are that are
matching you based off hopefully honest
answers yeah
versus at the bar it's like it's like
playing russian roulette you might meet
someone cool or something it's also dark
it's dark yeah you're throwing alcohol
into the mix yeah yeah
that's true yeah why is that more
acceptable it's like
let's go somewhere danger because then
like
i remember the argument where it's like
oh if you do it online like you're
you're not being your real person or
whatever but no one's being the real
person when they go to the bar either
you're dressing extra
nice or different you're trying to
pretend and you sometimes you flat out
lie like dudes would have like goals
worth like
like they would have strategies where
it's like all right you act like a big
shot
and i'm i'mma pretend like i work for
you or whatever
and then like they gamify that [ __ ] too
true you can be just as phony
in person as you are online yeah it's
like i'm gonna pretend like i'm a
japanese billionaire
let's rent our buddy's car like and then
and then you can like be my servant and
then like
we'll go up to these girls and like like
there's like guys that [ __ ] do [ __ ]
like that too so it's like
i've heard of strategy that blew my mind
because i was like you guys are that
[ __ ] low you can't just say what's up
but it works it grabs the attention of
people because i've
i'm like what the [ __ ] this is actually
like you're they want to hang out
because they were tracking a certain
type you know
they're not attracting like quality
right it's different kind of they want
clout right
but i feel like if you've been that way
in real life you're still that way
online
yep now yeah so you can't really make
this blanket statement of like one is
fake and
one is real true that's true um
um oh yeah and then another interesting
um
finding is that people finding love
through dating apps have had
have shown stronger fertility desires
and intentions than those who found
their partners
offline yeah it's like they're actually
procreate
procreate yeah like i don't know i'm am
i still trying to wrap my brain around
utility desires does that mean
just [ __ ] or you know like babies
having babies and starting a family yeah
that kind of makes
sense to me a bit because like i don't
know it seems like if you are
purposely trying to find a partner and
you're trying and
if you're trying to find a partner like
romantic partner you're trying to
most people the next step after marriage
is to have a baby
so then if people are meeting in person
and it's like oh i wasn't really looking
for a partner but oh [ __ ] we're together
like who knows where this is going to
lead and maybe they
don't really want to have kids hmm
interesting yeah
i don't know like i feel like that could
be that could be the case or maybe
people like tried dating online
and then you know it didn't work were
dating offline
and didn't work out they hop on dating
online
and that's when they kind of like start
thinking about procreating and settling
down
yeah that makes sense because now i
think it's just so uh
the apps are so advanced now that like i
think you can even pick the radius
that you want like this net to be casted
so there's like a
10 mile 30 miles and then you can
worldwide yeah
and then you can put in your interest so
like the algorithm of like how it just
kind of like
shuffles through people for you like you
really want to put down as much
genuine honest information i changed my
profile
so that you can get quality candidates i
suppose right because if you're just
bullshitting then
you don't really put that much effort
into it i mean also
i feel like the people that are on on
dating sites like what you just said you
have to put in
like your most vulnerable like truest
self of yourself like you have to know
yourself
really well to even do that step and
then once you get to know yourself
that's how you attract a partner that
complements you very well and then i
think that's why those algorithms work
like the more info you put in
it's because you know yourself better
and that's how they can actually find
compatibility
yeah interesting i was just thinking how
most guys are probably like how can i
get [ __ ] which picture is gonna get me
that ass
perhaps i bet that's how a lot of dudes
understand
just game finding it another and finally
to end this video on
uh the last interesting find that they
uh
they they came across was that higher
educated women
were getting with lower educated men so
true online
versus offline
why is that i don't know well okay
here's my theory the apps are photo
based prior prioritization so the hotter
they are the dumber so like a lot of
it's like kind of
like just the way they look in these
photos attract
higher educated women to lower educated
men for some reason because lower
educated men tend to focus on their
looks more
that's what it kind of sounds like yeah
i don't know what do you think
yeah i was thinking like interesting if
you've
gone to these top tier universities
some of the girls can be very pretty and
you you see their choices of guys and
they don't have much
and vice versa so if you think about it
right
rich smart dudes the stereotype is they
want bimbos
smart successful women they also want
bimbos they want ben bass
why the [ __ ] would they want an ugly
nerd for girls
ugly nerds don't want ugly nerds that's
true true
i want hot nerds that's true i can see
where you're going i mean like everybody
wants to date
physically attractive right so like
doesn't matter what the education is
i that's what that's what i think it's
like yeah she's highly educated why is
she getting with this dumb [ __ ]
because he looks [ __ ] good maybe
[Music]
m
[Music]